我们是不是得过那种经验啊
就是做交易赚了点小钱
心满意足就跑了
那你有没有想过
要怎么样才能把这些小小小小的好运
变成真正能够改变你整个账户的巨大获利
今天我们不谈运气
我们要来聊聊交易的结构
你是不是也常常觉得很偶
明明看对了方向
股票也真的涨了
但最后平仓的时候
那个获利小到自己都有一点不好意思
放心啦
这真的不是你一个人的问题
今天我们就来好好地把它拆解清楚
好那要怎么解决这个问题
其实我们要先从我们最习惯的那种交易方式开始看起
这就是大多数人会遇到的所谓的小赢困境
来我们直接举个例子
假设我们在100块买进一档股票
然后停损设在95块
听起来很合理对不对
然后股价涨到108块了
心里就想
哎不错哦
有赚哦
赶快跑
于是就把它卖掉了
表面上看
这当然是一笔成功的交易啊
好我们把数字参开来看
你看这笔交易
我们最多最多
愿意赔多少
就是五块钱嘛
从一百跌到九十五
那结果呢
我们赚了八块钱
所以你看
风险跟报酬的比
大概就是一比一点六
有赚钱
当然是好事
心里也踏实嘛
但问题就出在这里
赚的真的太少了
这就是我们说的那个典型的小银陷阱
那如果我们只改变其中一件事就这么一个小小的的改变,结果会差多少?好,我们来看第二种方法,也就是所谓持有的力量。
你注意看,
我们的进场点跟停损点,
跟刚刚完全一样。
一样是100块买,
就数块停损,
唯一的差别在哪?
就是我们这次不急着买了。
我们决定让货里飞一下,
一路报到趋势好像要反转了,
我们才出场,
比如说最后出在120块
哇神奇的地方就来了
我们的风险有没有变
完全没有
还是那5块钱
可是你看我们的报酬
直接从8块一口气跳到20块
这样算下来
风险报酬比直接冲到1比4
这可是第一种方法的两倍半
你想想看
我们只不过是改变了出场的策略而已
结果竟然差这么多
好不过你以为这样就结束了吗
不,刚刚那两种都只是暖身而已
现在我们要来揭晓真正职业级玩家的秘密武器
也就是在获利的时候加码
我们叫它金字塔加码法
这个方法的精髓是什么
就是一开始我们不要下重本
只用一小部分资金去试水温
一样在100块进场
但可能只买个一张测试一下
OK,只过股价真的照我们想的上涨了
涨到106块
这就证明什么
证明我们看对了嘛
这个时候
才在已经赚钱的基础上勇敢再加码两张最后一样在趋势看起来不对劲的时候比如说120块把全部的部位都出清来来来我们来算一下这样能赚多少
第一张最早买的那一张
是不是赚了20块
120减100吗
后来加码的那两张呢
是从106报到120
所以一张赚14块
两张就是28块
所以总共赚了多少
20加上28等于48块
但这整个结构
最最最神奇的地方是什么
就是我们从头到尾
真正冒的初始风险
还是只有第一张单的那五块钱
为什么
因为我们是在做对了
在已经赚钱了的情况下
才加码的
这根本就是用一个超小的风险
去撬动了一个48块的巨大报酬
所以你看
最终的风险报酬比
达到了多金人的数字
1比9.6
各位
这就是结构的力量
看到这里
你又没有发现一件
可以说是
有点残酷的事实
没关系
我们把这三种做法
摆在一起看
你马上就懂了
你看这张表
是不是一目了然
注意看哦
这三种策略
我们的进场点
和初始风险
完全一样
都是那五块钱
但是就只是因为
初场和加码的策略不一样
这个风险报酬比
就从1.6
一路飙到4.0
最后冲到9.6
这张图又更直接了对吧
你看这个长条图
我们的报酬是怎么呈现这种
根本是指数级的增长而最关键的是这一切的一切都是建立在那个一开始就固定好的完全相同的风险之上
所以说了这么多
这一切的关键到底是什么
是我们突然变神了
预测变准了吗
不是
完全不是
这跟预测一点关系都没有
这是一种
根本性的思维转变
我想强调的重点是
你根本不需要提高
你的胜率
你想想看
我们这三个例子
进场点是不是都一样
这就代表
我们的转确率
根本没变
真正改变的是
我们怎么去处理
赚钱跟赔钱
这两件事
我们以前都以为
哇要大赚
一定是要看得超准
但今天我们这样
拆解下来
你却发现
真正的关键
是你怎么去管理
一笔已经在赚钱的单子
说穿了就会一句话
让你的亏损
永远都很小
然后让你的获利
尽可能的变大
好
这也就是我们今天
最想带给大家的核心观念
不要再把所有的利器都花在
哎呀
我怎么才能看对多一点
猜对多一点
不是的
你应该把利器花在
设计你的交易结构
去确保你赔钱的时候
都只是赔在小部位上
而你下大柱的时候
都已经是市场证明
你看对了的时候
所以咯
看完我们今天的分析
我想留给你一个问题
去思考一下
在你下一次进场之前
你会怎么去设计你的这一笔交易
而不是只有预测它的走势呢?